what are your two different types of
doing nothing so I think that's really
really important and I think that when
we're taught so much how to work and
we're not taught that well how to take
time and know when we're probably a
little bit burnt out and all of these
different things that actually if we
took rest we would be much better
tomorrow the idea of planned nothing and
[ __ ] it nothing are the fact that
actually I believe wholeheartedly in
time management I believe that time
management is Stress Management knowing
your boundaries and getting to know how
you're most productive and how you're
happiest [ __ ] it nothing is essentially
being able to be like [ __ ] it not doing
that understanding our human limits and
our boundaries and being able to just
say I'm not going to do that and I know
I'm not going to do that and I'm okay
with not doing that is one of the most
important things you can do for your
productivity and your time management
and your self-care